the best way to sell is to have the
person feel like you understand them and
the best way for someone to feel
understood is for you to actually give a
[ __ ] if you actually give a [ __ ] you
will know what questions to ask in what
order because those are the questions
that you would naturally ask the reason
scripts were even invented is to mimic
or structure a conversation between
somebody who cares and someone that they
can help that is what a sale is we're
breaking their beliefs we're coaching
them to the conclusion that they have
not been able to make up at this point
which is that they need to work with us
in order to solve their problem and we
should be okay with the fact that i
would like to provide value to this
person so that i can break their beliefs
around this whether they work with me or
not this is still the type of solution
that they're going to need and if you
can approach it like that you stop
having your ego tied up in your closing
percentages in your numbers and instead
you start helping people on the phone
and by extension you will sell more
deals